This is it. I can't believe it.
It's our final hit.
Come on you. Let's go to Kat's party.
Soft launch.
Don't say soft launch.
God, I completely forgot.
What do we do for a living?
We definitely don't kill people
for a living.
We work in security.
Exactly.
Get in here!
Are you alright with that thing, mate?
I think now I'm pretty expert.
Woah!
If someone's got something you want,
you need to take control of the situation.
You need to forget about Fran and move on.
You got me now. And I'm not going anywhere.
You ready?
Show time.
Bloody hell!
Bring him to me.
I love you.
I love you too.
Should we kiss then?
Why do you have to make everything so weird?
Never, never mess with a funky fresh crew.